now to the world wind week on Wall
Street that stoked fears of a downturn
in the economy President Trump is trying
to calm weary investors as he plans to
tout low unemployment in his push for
re-election in 2020 but this centerpiece
of his campaign effort comes as some
economists warn of another recession
taking shape Paula Reid is with the
president as he prepares to wrap up a
week at his Golf Club in Bedminster New
Jersey Paula good morning
good morning Michelle that's right the
president will soon head back to
Washington after spending some time here
at his New Jersey golf club but when he
gets back to the White House he will
face a harsh new reality these growing
concerns about a recession in 2020 and
this comes just as the president was
trying to make a strong economy his
primary pitch for reelection Wall Street
appeared to recover by Friday after a
tumultuous week and President Trump
insists he is the only one who can keep
it that way you have no choice but to
vote for me because your 401ks down the
tubes everything's going to be down the
tubes at a rally in New Hampshire
Thursday the president put a positive
spin on the skittish markets we have the
best but as the Dow dropped 800 points
on Wednesday its worst day so far this
year the president had a conference call
with top CEOs including the heads of
three banks still the president
continued to project confidence I think
the longer the trade war goes on the
weaker China gets in the stronger we get
but even some conservative economists
are concerned if you look at the effect
of some of these policies most notably
the administration's trade policy that
is going to slow the economy and some
economists think that that might even
tip the economy into recession something
nearly 70% of CFOs said they fear will
happen by the end of next year according
to a new survey by Duke University and
amid the growing global concerns
president Trump huddled in New Jersey
Friday with his national security team
to discuss his plan to fulfill a promise
troop withdrawal from Afghanistan
the White House didn't say if the
president brought up other international
issues in that meeting including his
controversial proposal to buy Greenland
the president returns to Washington late
tomorrow Jeff okay Paula thank you very
much